MALE SPEAKER: And welcome
to another talk at
Google Experience.
If you're here in
the audience, you've
probably seen how amazing
the restaurant is yourself,
down in the North Beach,
Tony's Pizza Napoletana--
as I feign my way
through Italian.
But we have the man
himself here today.
He's here to speak to us
about his new book, "The Pizza
Bible," which is
everything it says
it is, the ultimate guide to the
variety and diversity of pizzas
throughout the world, with
special advice for the home
chef, as well.
Tony's Pizza is a San
Francisco institution,
a thing of pure legend, and
he himself has won, I think,
11 international pizza awards.
And then, I guess they decided,
to be fair to the other people,
to elect him out
of the competition.
So he's a judge in
emeritus now, I guess.
So without further
ado, looks like we
have some dough on the line.
So please join me in
welcoming Tony to Google.
Thank you.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
TONY GEMIGNANI:
Who was here first?
I saw you.
There's one.
Who else was here first?
No, I don't know about that one.
I'll give you one, too.
I have a couple.
I don't know if he was.
Anybody have a kid?
Baby?
Like "baby," baby?
Somebody have a baby?
Some-- nobody has babies?
I just had a baby.
I'm going to save it
in case somebody--
Well, where did "The Pizza
Bible" originate from?
How did it all happen?
It really goes back
to the beginning.
And even when we
go further back,
I grew up in Fremont, Italian,
Portuguese, Spanish family.
My mom cooked.
And when I say my mom
cooked, she was a housewife.
We would come home
from school at 3:00.
My dad would come home
from work at 6:00.
We'd watch my mom
cook for three hours.
That was my brother, Frank,
and I watched my mom cook.
We grew up on a farm.
We had fresh produce.
We had apricots, cherries,
fava beans-- I farmed.
So being used to that,
growing up around food
was a staple in our household.
Pizza Friday
nights-- Uncle Joe's
was a local place,
independent guy.
He was Italian.
I was a little kid.
My grandpa would bring me in.
I'd get a double
cheese, and I thought
it was the greatest
thing in the world.
And then, when I
was 18, my brother
had the idea of
opening up a pizzeria.
It was in Castro Valley.
And that's where I
made my first pizza.
And when you think of my
first pizza, first pizza
professionally, where somebody
paid for it, and they came in.
My brother taught me the basics.
Get some flour on your dough.
Stretch it out.
I thought it was
the greatest thing.
Here in front of you
is this living organism
that I wanted to make better.
I wanted to figure it out.
And I don't think we can
always figure it out.
It's something you want to
master, but at the same time,
you still want to respect.
But at that time, I was
trying to figure out
what hasn't been done.
When you're a young chef,
you're a young pizzaiolo--
that's a pizza
maker in Italian--
you're always trying to figure
out what's never been done,
what type of out-of-the-box
pizzas you can do.
And when you get older
and you get wiser,
sometimes some of the
simplest things in life
are the greatest things.
So I was known for
this pizza acrobat,
this guy that threw it around.
And when people used
to come in, kids
thought it was the greatest
thing in the world.
I got pretty good at it.
I would do things as
people came around.
And what was that?
It was a hell of
a marketing idea.
It was an idea that if
people came in and saw
me throw, let's help
a lot of them do.
Guy in the red-- all right!
Look at that.
So kids came in.
Parents came in.
When kids came in, they said,
wow, what's he doing, daddy?
And when parents came
in, they would say, wow,
I remember when that guy used
to do that when I was younger.
It was a lost art.
It was something so simple.
Yet you're trying to
manipulate it, do tricks to it,
and it was fun.
Well, I won in the '90s.
And I think when
I was introduced,
I was banned from competing.
I retired and competed.
I was banned from Italy.
I couldn't compete.
I won so many times
in acrobatics.
Made how-to videos,
I got millions
of dollars worth of
free advertising.
Here we were, this little mom
and pop shop, and it was great.
I got to travel
around the world,
and I got to make pizzas.
I got to toss pizzas
at places from Fargo
to Florida, to
Belgium, to Thailand.
I was traveling
with Thai acrobats
when I was 23 years
old across Thailand.
I got to see how
pizza's made all over.
And when you think of
"The Pizza Bible," how
did this guy become good
enough or an expert enough
to be able to do that?
It was a lot of times.
It was 16 years of
traveling on the road.
I was fortunate.
A lot of pizza guys
know one style.
They stay in their restaurant.
We do New York.
That's it.
Well, I was fortunate enough
to work with guys from Detroit,
see St. Louis-style pizza, work
in New York, work all over,
and really understand
regional pizzas
and Italian-style
regional pizzas.
It was funny.
I went to Naples
in the year 2000.
I was on my honeymoon.
We're on our way to Sorrento.
I told my wife, I
got to go by Naples.
Here's this pizza
guy in the industry.
If you look at it,
it was the year 2000.
I got into the pizza
industry in 1991.
I thought I knew it all.
I said, I got to see this.
We want to Trianon.
We were going on the train,
got out, went to Trianon.
And it's a pizzeria in Naples.
There's Trianon, Da
Michele, Di Matteo,
Presidente-- it's this
circle of great pizzerias.
I ordered a Margherita My wife
ordered this pizza lasagna.
It was like a combo pizza in
Naples, what you would call it.
And here was this pizza
sitting in front of me
that I didn't understand.
I looked at it.
It was a Margherita.
It's simple, but 900
degrees, 90 seconds.
It was simple.
It was basil, olive
oil, sea salt.
It was mozzarella fiordilatte.
It was a cheese pizza
with basil on it.
But it wasn't that.
I didn't know how to do it.
I looked at it.
I don't know how to make this.
Here, I'm this pizza guy and
whatever you want to call me,
and I didn't really
know how to do it.
It was a realization
of I knew nothing.
I said to myself,
I know nothing.
And my wife's looking at
like, you're a nutcase.
What are you talking about?
I said, I don't know
how to make this.
This is something that
was done 150 years ago.
And here, I'm this guy
in this pizza industry,
and I don't even
know how to do it.
It wasn't the thing like I
know how to play PlayStation,
but I never learned how to
play Commodore or Atari.
It was a little bit like
that, but it was just
this basic thing that
was just such a craft.
And it was amazing.
So I had to reteach
myself all over again.
I had to do my own research.
It was a lot of work.
I saw the industry evolving.
Back then in 2000,
Neapolitan, coal-- all
that that's going on right now,
artisan pizza, wasn't that big.
I saw our industry
going in that direction.
It was crazy.
I started the first team
in the pizza industry
from the US Pizza
team to an elite team
called the World
Pizza Champions.
We traveled around the world.
I did a lot, but
it was all going
towards the food category.
Forget the acrobats.
That's done.
Let's focus on food.
And there's a funny thing that
happened right at that time
at the Alameda County fair.
I do 30 shows.
It was cooking and acrobatics.
It was right around 2000.
The chef, Courtney Townsend,
that was the head of that.
It was a hot day.
It was 109 in Pleasanton.
It was just really a mess.
I got done doing my show.
I was out of breath.
I was tired.
There were five people
in the audience.
It was a Tuesday.
It was a horrible day.
It was just one of those days
that nobody was at the fair.
It was a 2:00 show.
I was done.
I was a mess.
And Courtney went to
me and said, you know,
you're doing it now.
But I don't think anyone wants
to see a 50-year-old on stage
doing what you're doing.
It was funny, because
Courtney was right.
And there was a time
in my life that I
said, meaning you
should focus on food.
You're a great guy
cooking, she told me later.
You know how to
do amazing things.
Why don't you focus on the food?
And she said that, and I got it.
Some people would
say, screw you.
I'm done.
I like to throw pizzas.
A lot of guys in
our industry do.
So I focused on food, and
the Food Network came around.
It was hot.
There was one
competition that I won,
and I won a number
on the Food Network.
But the one I wanted to win
was "Best Pizza in the US."
And if you guys
have seen that show,
it was a pizza called
the Cal Italia.
That was a pinnacle
moment in my career,
just because it's like,
wow, I finally got something
with food.
And I was striving for that.
Pizza schools were
originating everywhere.
They're all over Italy,
France, just everywhere.
In the US, there
wasn't that many.
I was this hot guy
in the industry
that three different
schools wanted
me to start their chapter in
San Francisco or in California.
I visited three, and I
saw one that I loved.
I liked it because
their book from the '80s
to the '90s to that
time was getting
bigger and thicker and thicker.
They progressed.
And it wasn't just
about making recipes.
It was about the chemistry
behind the dough,
simple sugars, yeast,
complex sugars.
There was the whole chemistry
behind the whys and the whats.
And when you're an owner,
you're an operator,
you're a home cook,
you're a chef,
you're trying to figure out,
why did my dough blow up?
Why did it go flat?
Why didn't it brown correctly?
Why is it not working?
And when you're an
owner and operator,
you want to try to
figure those things out.
So the chemistry behind dough,
the chemistry behind cooking
was at this school,
and I liked that.
And nobody else had that.
It was considered one the
oldest schools in Italy.
I went and got my
master's from that school.
And I was able to certify.
So in the year
2005, I had a book
that came out called
"Pizza" that was good.
It's a good book.
It did very, very well.
But if you look at what "Pizza"
is to "The Pizza Bible,"
the progression
is pretty dynamic.
But during that
year, they said, hey,
when are you going to
open your school up, Tony?
I said, well, Tony's pizza
Napoletana's not here yet,
because we opened in '09.
I was just leaving
Paisano's, my brother,
trying to figure out
what I was going to do.
I wanted to do a school.
It was a lot going on, actually,
for me in my life at that time.
Nobody understood the model,
Tony's Pizza Napoletana.
Several ovens, every style--
practically every style
of pizza.
How are you going to do it?
How are you going to operate it?
It's never going to work.
Nine out of 10 people
told me they don't get it,
and it's not going to happen.
It's not going to work.
You're probably going
to go out of business.
And these are operators.
These are guys in the
industry where you look up to.
So I decided to.
And at that time, I was
practicing Neapolitan pizza
at my house.
I was a guy who was certified in
pizza, but I wasn't Neapolitan.
Let me just tell you,
that Neapolitan arena
is in an arena of its own.
Guys that run pizza classica,
Sicilian-style pizza,
Pizza Romana--
that's a category.
But the Neapolitan
category is very hard.
It's a trade that you don't
see it around that often.
And people may say "Neopolitan,"
but most of its neo-Neapolitan.
But Neopolitan's
very, very difficult.
I started practicing in my
backyard with beehive ovens,
and we were talking about
that a little bit ago.
I had ingredients sent
to me to my house.
I was working like a
dog trying to figure out
this craft on my own, from wood
boxes to deseeding San Marzano
tomatoes, to trying
to figure out
the best way I could
make this pizza.
I entered in '07.
I brought the first team from
the US to Naples to compete,
and I won that World Pizza Cup.
It was probably a landmark
win in the pizza industry.
I was escorted out by
police when I won that,
because they thought I was
going to get stabbed or shot.
It was a crazy moment of
2,000 people in this arena,
most of them pizzaiolos.
And then, there was this
American table of nine
that police came to and
said, don't get excited.
And you're like, what?
And then, they
call your name out,
and you can't really
get too excited.
It was a surreal moment.
It was a pinnacle moment in
my career and in the industry.
And after that win, I decided
to find North Beach, San
Francisco, and put
Tony's Pizza Napoletana
and the International
School of Pizza there.
And when you think
of "The Pizza Bible,"
that's where it all
started, out of Tony's.
Nine out of 10 people
said I'd never make it.
It was '08, '09, building,
horrible economy.
You're a young chef.
Go to the Mission.
I heard that so many times.
I don't want to
go to the Mission.
Oh, you're going to have
a hard time doing it.
Any time somebody tells me I
can't do it, or I don't get it,
or why are you doing that, it's
when you want to show them.
And everybody said it.
But doing it in North
Beach, Little Italy-- I
got married across the street.
I hung out there when
I was 19 years old.
You're Italian.
I want to do it in North Beach.
I love the Mission,
don't get me wrong.
But is it easy in the Mission
for me to do it at that time?
It was.
Was it hard to try and do
it at North Beach, where
they considered that corner
one of the worst corners
at that time?
Everybody was going under.
It was seven to nine
different places
going under when I opened,
and it was very, very tough.
So the odds were against me.
So we opened with five ovens.
Now, we have seven.
We have coal, electric,
wood, gas, rotating gas.
We have practically every style
of pizza other than Chicago,
which I opened up a new
concept called Capo's.
And it was groundbreaking.
It was innovative.
When you think of
groundbreaking,
Google is groundbreaking.
Google is innovative.
Obviously, we're
here, and it's one
of the most amazing
campuses, areas,
places to work--
wherever you would
like to call it-- that
I've ever been to.
So to create something that
was monumental in an industry,
it was exciting times.
When you're thinking of that
startup, or the early years
of Google and now, of course,
it's that exciting time to say,
we can do it.
We can do it.
And that was really
exciting to me,
bringing regional styles,
national styles, to a place
where everybody lives.
If you're from St. Louis,
I have the provel cheese
that you probably are used to.
If you're from Wisconsin,
you've heard of brick cheese.
And you're making Detroit-style
pizzas in Detroit,
I'm using the brick cheese.
It's important when
you think of books
that have been written is, do
we have room for another book?
Is there room for
another pizza book?
Yes, there was room
for "The Pizza Bible."
I wrote one 10 years ago.
I wrote a children's
book after that.
But when it comes
down to it, do we
need another book
on our shelves?
And "The Pizza Bible" is a book
that every professional will
have, and every home
chef will have to get.
It's a user-friendly book
that is unlike any book.
Is everything in
it that I wanted?
Did I get everything in it?
Not everything got in it.
I could have been a $100 book.
Fortunately, we wanted
slot it correctly
for a home user
and a professional,
where it was affordable.
98% of everything that I wanted
in that book was in that book.
There's a few styles
that were left out,
and I left them out for
reasons that I didn't really
feel they were the
greatest-tasting styles
out there.
But when it comes to
"The Pizza Bible,"
and when it comes to the
styles, it's a book--
now, when you look at books,
resources are so important.
The resources in this are
professional resources.
We tell you where to
buy All Trumps flour.
That's good for New
York-style pizza.
Power flour, that's
great for your home oven.
When you think of
specific ingredients,
a lot of home chefs
say, what am I
doing wrong when
they make pizza?
It's the first question
I hear all the time.
Or they just come to you
and make that statement.
Well, what am I doing wrong?
I can't do it like
the pizza operators.
It's not that they're
doing something wrong.
A lot of times, they're just
not using the right ingredients.
Ingredients are a key.
Quality ingredients are a key.
You go out to your food court
out here and you're eating,
and everything's quality.
It tastes great.
It's amazing.
It's fresh.
And obviously, I've
been to food courts
like this where everything
tasted horrible.
It's a key element
to cooking, and it's
important to understand.
And the chemistry
behind dough, and I
talk a lot about that--
understanding salt
and how it affects your dough,
how your water is so important.
The variables from day-to-day
operations are amazing.
Humidity-- when it comes
to hot, cold, elevation,
they're all factors when
it comes to your dough.
And it always comes
back to your dough,
because your dough's
the hardest thing.
So I'd love to be able to
take some questions from you.
I had a couple questions
I answered in my speech
right now, that somebody emailed
to me that wanted to know.
I don't know who it was,
but it was somebody,
unless they're just
going to watch it later.
But if you have any questions,
I'd love to answer them.
If you want to have some books
signed, I'd love to sign some.
AUDIENCE: Without going into the
specifics of Neopolitan pizza,
what is it that makes it
different, for those people who
haven't been to Napoli, and
who haven't tried it really?
TONY GEMIGNANI: That's
a great question.
So Neapolitan
pizza-- it's soupy.
It's wet.
It's sloppy wet, sometimes.
When you have a
Neapolitan pizza,
it's 90 seconds, 60
seconds, 900 degrees,
a fresh mozzarella that's wet,
olive oil that's obviously wet.
It's a pizza that
unfortunately-- it's
a few good questions,
actually, in one.
Sometimes, what we grow
up with in the US--
you've been to places that
say "New York-style pizza."
And there's nothing
New York about it,
until a purist comes in
or a traditionalist comes
in and says, "this is New York."
And then, you're
battling it out, saying,
well, I've been eating at
this place for five years,
and they call it New York.
And you're like, well,
they have the wrong oven.
They have the wrong flour.
The cheese is horrible.
Everything's wrong about it.
So it's tough when
you're in the US.
There's a lot of places that
call themselves "Neopolitan
pizza," and there's nothing
Neapolitan about it.
That's why I said the
name "neo-Neapolitan."
Places like A16 is Neapolitan.
Una Pizza Napoletana
is Neopolitan.
Tony's Pizza Napoletana
There's other pizzerias
out there that aren't.
I don't like people to
get-- not necessarily
lied to-- but if I'm
getting something that's
called something, I
want it to be that.
And again, that's
very important.
Neapolitan pizza is
typically a 00 flour.
And if you've ever
heard of 00 flour,
it's a type of refinement.
Typically, those
flours are from Naples.
It's a very simple sauce.
It's sea-salted San Marzanos.
There's not oregano
or garlic, or all
these different seasonings
in this tomato sauce.
It's basil.
It's olive oil.
It's simple.
Really under the
guidelines, it's
three different types of pizzas,
the marinara, the Margherita,
the Margherita extra.
You could put other
items on those pizzas,
but the simplicity of that
pizza is what it's all about.
And like I said, some
of the simplest things
are the hardest things.
It's not about pepperoni
on top of that.
It's not about putting
your basil on after.
It's that basil is
cooked on that pizza.
And that's the style.
It's not cooked
at three minutes.
It's not cooked at five minutes.
It's charred, chewy,
wet, sometimes soupy.
It's not crispy.
Charred and crispy are
two different things.
Charred is charred.
Crispy is you fold it up,
you eat it, and it cracks
but it doesn't break.
So it's very important
to understand that.
There's no paste or
agents that you put in
to sweeten the sauce.
It's about the tomato.
It's about the flour.
It's about the basil, if that
makes a little sense to you.
Yeah, it's a soft, very
delicate-type pizza.
And you could eat
it with a fork.
It could be uncut.
It could not.
I cut mine, because
people would be pissed off
and send it back to me
all the time saying,
can you cut my pizza?
And when you're on a line
doing 500 pizzas a day
on one single line,
you'll go crazy.
So yeah, 11.5, 12.5 inches, big.
You're not looking at
small, medium, extra large.
You could have a
starter in that dough.
Typically, there's not.
Some people right
now, the question
that somebody sent me was,
"What makes the perfect pizza?"
Somebody sent that to me
last night on an email.
And really, when I think of
a pizza, it's about balance.
It's not about
over-complex doughs.
It's not about the
sourest starter
that you have, and you're like,
"Do you taste this starter?"
I like to taste a
little bit of starter,
and I like to taste a
little bit of complexity.
But when it comes
to a pizza, if I'm
using a great cheese, or
a great piece of basil,
or some really nice
olive oil and a sea salt,
I want to taste it and have
it take you through a journey.
I just don't want to have the
back of my mouth tasting sour.
And a lot of people
are trying to achieve
the most sour starter,
sourdough dough
that they're trying to achieve.
And really, when it
comes to me when cooking,
is I don't like it overseasoned
or under, or oversalted or not.
I like it to be about balance.
And that's the key
to great pizza.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned moving
from your old restaurant
and opening your place in North
Beach, and a lot of skepticism
from other people about
whether it would be successful.
And it's obviously
very successful now.
It's always packed in there.
So I'm curious as to
whether you encountered
unexpected challenges
with maintaining
a high quality of a large number
of different types of pizzas
at a high volume.
And a possibly
related question--
why 73 Margheritas per day?
TONY GEMIGNANI: That's
a good question.
So 73-- we'll start off.
I went on St. Anthony
Day, San Antonio day.
When I won that
competition-- well
before I won that
competition, I was
sitting with a bunch of
pizzaiolos, Neapolitans.
I knocked over some
wine at the table.
It was for lunch.
And I went to clean it up, and
the guy grabbed my hand, said,
don't.
In Italy, if you spill
it, rub it on your head.
It'll give you good luck.
You're going to win tonight.
And they said, it's
St. Anthony Day.
It's like your second birthday.
It's your lucky-- I'm Anthony,
so it's your lucky day today.
So it was a joke during lunch.
So that the day is
always on 6/13, June 13.
So I added the six and
one, kept the three.
I was born in '73.
And when we're out, we're out.
And we run out every day.
We could do 100
Margaritas that day.
But after we get to 73-- and
it's done with the San Felice.
I still make it with
the specific flour.
I still keep it in wood boxes.
It's that pizza, that one.
It's a little better
actually than it
was from that winning day.
If I go back to that pizza and
look at it, it was interesting.
It was a tough competition.
Nobody wanted me to win.
Every single judge that I
had was just pissed off.
It was an odd day.
But those judges asked
for another piece.
When you judge a
competition-- I've
judged a few different world
competitions-- you never--
you're done eating.
You're a mess.
You feel horrible.
You never ask, hey, can
I get another slice?
You never do that.
So they asked for another slice.
So the team had one slice
to split for all of us.
We had one piece that day.
That was one of the best
pizzas I ever made in my life.
We ate it.
We said, OK, it's good,
we said to ourselves.
Is it the winner?
We said, we don't know.
The politics in
pizza, we didn't go
in thinking we were
going to win, trust me.
Maybe a 3rd would be great,
but it was our first time.
It was one of those-- so
it's really interesting.
When it comes to the styles
that we've incorporated
and the more-- are we better
than we were on day one?
Tony's is better.
My crew in the back, 70%
of them have been with me
from the very beginning.
Chef Laura, Tiago-- they're
both worlds champions now.
So I've carried
this 11-time world
champion, won all these things.
A lot of people don't
know that Laura, my chef,
has one two world titles.
Tiago has won a world title,
and Matt at Capo's won a world
title in Italy.
So I have a seasoned crew of
Babe Ruths and Michael Jordans,
really.
At the beginning, if you came
into Tony's, it was hard.
It was a new concept.
Guys I got from North Beach
Pizza, Cybelle's, whoever
came-- and bad habits.
They needed to know how to
make pizzas a certain way.
There were things
that nobody even
knew what the heck they were.
Nobody was really doing those.
So I would say we've expanded a
lot since then, mostly because
of the space.
Did I open up with
enough refrigeration?
No.
Did I open up with
enough storage?
No.
Thank God I bought
the deli next to me,
and I added the coal oven
and the roto-flex oven.
But now, we're making
our pasta fresh.
We didn't start that in '09.
We're pulling mozzarella
for one specific pizza.
It's the Guinness pizza that
we make, only so many a day.
We case all of our sausage now.
If you look at what Tony's
was in '09, it's amazing.
It was great.
But if you look at it
now, it's an institution.
And I'm proud of it.
And when you think of
Lombardi's of the East Coast,
I think you think of
Tony's of the West Coast.
There's no place
that you can go where
you have a Roman, Sicilian,
Detroit, St. Louis.
And I get operators
in every day.
And they'll get
every single one.
They're looking at the bottom.
They're like, oh,
that's what it is, huh?
And it's funny.
And they're quizzing me.
And I'm like, so what
restaurant do you own?
Or which one are
you going to open?
It's cool.
And it's just great that
it's in San Francisco.
And it needed to
be in North Beach.
I love that neighborhood,
and I still do.
So yeah, I think it's better.
Yeah, it's way better.
It's hard, though,
keeping consistency up.
Ordering the product's fine.
The consistency's the toughest.
I'm lucky I have a great crew.
And my general
manager right now,
if you look at our management,
it's never been better.
I'm pretty happy with them.
AUDIENCE: So, my whole
family are pizza nuts,
and we love having it.
We have it several times a week.
Unfortunately, one of them was
just diagnosed with celiac.
And I'm wondering if
it's possible to make
a really good pizza
that is gluten-free.
TONY GEMIGNANI: There is,
and we make a great one.
It's hard to make.
It took me two and 1/2 years
to come up with that recipe.
Celiac-- you hear
it all the time.
Why does everyone have
gluten free allergies?
What's going on?
When I was younger, did
my parents hear about it?
No.
My grandparents-- nobody
had it, and now it's here.
It's interesting
to talk about that.
It's not that we did
something wrong, at least,
or that we changed.
The grain has changed
over the years.
You're seeing a lot of
ancient grains right now.
grains that are not complex.
It's grains that were
from 2,000 years ago.
Every time they
picked that grain,
reharvested it, and
changed it over the years,
that grain became
very, very different.
And there's multiple grains
inside a bread or a flour.
And then, when we eat it, our
body doesn't recognize it.
And they don't process it, and
we're getting sick from it.
We did it naturally.
I don't think we did
it really on purpose.
It's just farmers did it.
You reharvest.
You find better
areas to replant.
You try and get the
strongest one, the best one.
So the chromosomes changed,
and it's different now.
And gluten-free is here.
It's here to stay.
There was something said
yesterday that, is it a fad?
I don't think it is at all.
I sell 350 gluten-frees a week.
I sold 50 gluten-frees a
week two and 1/2 years ago.
It's elevating.
What makes a good gluten-free?
There's a few things
I like to add.
Agave nectar, I like to add
to it, to slightly sweeten it.
I like to add some
rosemary and thyme,
I add to mine, to make it
a little more exciting.
You can add egg whites
to it to fluff it,
because a lot of times,
they're just really super thin.
But when you look at binding
agents like potato starches
and xanthan gum, you always
need some sort of binding agent.
I'm not big on egg
in my gluten-free.
Especially in Italy, if you
ever go compete in gluten-free.
If you ever put egg in it,
you always come in last.
They hate it.
They hate the additives.
They're trying to
get more natural.
Rice flour, tapioca
flour-- those
are the two key
flours that I like.
So yeah, it is hard.
The water absorption rate--
the leavening agent--
when you think of gluten,
there's four proteins, really,
in flour, and there's two
proteins that are missing.
So when you want to make dough
and have it rise in a ball,
there's a gluten net that
makes it very, very strong.
And like a helium
balloon, you blow it up,
and it's hold forever.
Unfortunately, gluten-free
doesn't have that,
so it's tough to make
a flavor profile in it,
because it's hard
to-- you can only
put so much yeast
in it to make it
taste the way you want it to.
But you don't want
to over-yeast it,
because then it'll just
be all wrong for you.
You've got to come to Tony's
and try our gluten-free.
You'll love it.
Cooking on a stone is important.
We have one dedicated oven.
We don't put our gluten-frees in
the same oven, which you really
shouldn't do.
We try to make it away
from where the flour is.
We do as much as we can to get
it away from all the flour.
I think it's important
when you go to a pizzeria,
you should ask.
Do you put your gluten-frees
in the same oven?
If they do, it's not the
best thing for you, actually.
But a lot of guys
are doing it wrong.
AUDIENCE: Do you have the
recipe and information
like that in the book?
TONY GEMIGNANI: I don't.
That's one I left out.
We mentioned "Cup
For Cup" in the book.
It's something my
partner, Susie--
I work with Thomas Keller,
that came out with that.
We thought it should be, if
we're doing a gluten-free book,
we may just save it for a
gluten-free book down the line.
And that's why we
didn't put it in.
We mentioned it, but we
didn't talk about it.
Come by.
You can always talk to me.
And if you wanted to buy a
couple shells to go and bring
it back, I would
sell them to you.
AUDIENCE: I had that same
experience that you did.
I was raised on
typical American pizza.
And then, I went this
last month to Rome.
And I had the most
incredible, simple,
and it was really almost
cracker-thin, just right
with the really
fresh ingredients.
Is that one of the
hardest pizzas to make,
and do you make that--
whatever that's called?
TONY GEMIGNANI: Yeah, I do
a thin crust Roman-style.
There's two-- Roman
can be tricky.
It could be thin.
It could be thick.
It could be cooked on a pan.
It could be cooked on a stone.
A lot of it is putting
ingredients on afterwards.
It's the finishing ingredients.
Typically, when
we're making a pizza,
we want to put everything
and cook it all at once.
But in our reality in
the pizza business,
our finish line, the
ingredients that go on after,
is typically bigger
than our make line.
So a lot of times
in Rome, you'll
see great fresh
mozzarella, basil, tomato,
peppers that are
all on it that are
very bright and
vibrant and fresh.
And most of those ingredients
go on after the bake.
Making a Roman-style
pizza-- yeah,
we have probably one of
the only Roman-style pizzas
in San Francisco.
Mine is thin, and that's
the way I like it.
I talk about it in the book.
Typically, your hydration
is slightly higher
when it comes to that.
More water in your dough
is a crispier crust.
We're always trying to achieve
more water in our dough.
And typically, Roman is
a high-hydrated dough.
Sometimes you think
more water in your dough
is a soupy pizza
and a wet pizza.
It's not.
During the baking process,
it's the opposite.
But yeah, I love
Roman-style pizza.
It's one of my favorites.
And I'm not knocking
American-style pizza.
I'm not saying American-style
pizza's horrible.
But there is one word called
digestability that's important.
And when it comes
to digestability,
it's a key factor to pizza.
When I'm making
dough today, am I
going to feed it to you in six
hours, 12 hours, 24 hours or 48
hours?
If I were to feed you
your dough at six hours,
you'll feel horrible.
You're not going
to feel too good.
You'll feel pretty good.
You'll feel great, because
yeast feeds on simple sugars.
The longer you let your yeast
feed, the less digesting
you have to do, meaning that
you're letting the yeast
feed on the simple
sugars for you.
So would I rather have old
dough than young dough?
Yeah.
And in America, typically
that dough, a lot of times,
are made that day.
And the worst thing you could
do is make dough this morning
and give it to you tonight.
You'll feel tired.
You'll feel like you
want to go to sleep.
And really when
it comes to that,
it's some of the
worst habits that you
see in our pizza industry.
You want to really
make your dough
and use it 24 hours,
36 hours, 48 hours.
And Italy understands that a
lot more-- Europe understands
that a lot more than we do.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So cooking
on a barbecue, pizza.
Any tips?
That's all I have
is a gas barbecue.
TONY GEMIGNANI:
Yeah, a lot of tips.
So what type of barbecue?
AUDIENCE: Gas barbecue.
TONY GEMIGNANI: So you have your
gas barbecue in front of you.
Do you have-- how many
flames do you have?
One, two, three?
AUDIENCE: Three, north-south.
TONY GEMIGNANI: Nice barbecue.
MALE SPEAKER 5:
And a glazed stone.
TONY GEMIGNANI: So no sugars
in that dough, one thing.
Even in my dough recipe, I
like a Neapolitan dough recipe
on the grill.
Why?
Because it's used to
cooking at high heat.
We're cooking at 900
in a wood-fired oven.
That dough can handle it.
Doughs that are
high-gluten, high-protein,
you don't want to use.
A lower-protein, a lower-gluten,
like a Caputo 00, is great.
No browning agent.
You don't need any oil on that.
You don't need a
fat in that dough.
I like to have my
grill on medium.
I like to go ahead and
get my dough ready.
And you could either lay it
on or slide it on with a peel.
You're going to
cook one side of it,
and that side is going
to have grill marks.
If it's on medium and it's
right, 30 seconds, 45 seconds.
MALE SPEAKER 5: Is
that 600 degrees?
TONY GEMIGNANI: Medium, if
you have it-- yeah, 600.
So you're going to slide
that right on your grill.
You're going to
then peel it off.
I'm going to go ahead and
lay that other side down,
the grilled side
down, top my pizza,
and then slide it
right back on my grill.
And this side is
the unmarked side.
The only way you can grill
a pizza correctly and cook
the top of it is
to close the lid.
If your bottom's now
done, you open it.
And 30 seconds later,
your ingredients
aren't melted that great.
It's half-done but
your bottom is burning,
just get a pizza pan,
a round pizza pan
that you would see, a
12-inch pan, 14-inch pan.
Put a little semolina
on it, and just go ahead
and put it right on pan
and then close your lid.
It'll save you about
two and 1/2 minutes
of burn time on that bottom.
It's just the key of
just doing it like that,
flipping it over, topping
it, putting it on, then
checking it.
And if it's burning,
just put a pan under it.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: It really does.
TONY GEMIGNANI:
It's really easy.
Grilling is probably the
easiest, when it comes to it.
Just have some extra
dough to play with.
AUDIENCE: People spend a lot
of time talking about flour,
but what about water?
People say that New York
water has something special
in it, or maybe Italian water.
TONY GEMIGNANI:
Italian water's great.
Water is a key ingredient.
It's the second-highest
ingredient
that goes in your dough.
A lot of people from
Florida have horrible pizza.
I run a school.
I certify 60 chefs a
year, approximately.
If I have somebody
from Florida, they'll
say the pizza sucks in Florida.
I say, yeah, it does.
So tell me how you
make your dough.
Well, we use this,
this, this, this.
Do you drink the
water in Florida?
They said, never.
It's horrible.
Do you use it on your dough?
Yes, all the time.
Doesn't make any sense.
Why?
Well, it's horrible.
It's cloudy.
It tastes horrible.
Moderately hard water
is important in dough.
Hard water is bad.
Vegas, I have reverse osmosis
in my restaurants in Vegas.
I have one in Sacramento.
San Francisco water's amazing.
As you get to San
Diego, it's bad.
LA isn't the greatest.
The Midwest is interesting.
Chicago is great.
New York's great.
Does water make your
dough taste great?
No, but it really makes
your dough perform.
It makes it conditioned,
doesn't make it dry.
Your yeast works way better
when your pockets can open.
So water does a lot of things.
Your leavening agent
makes your flavor.
Your yeast really makes
your flavor in your dough.
Great water and strong
yeast, the yeast
is going to overpower it.
So New York water, San
Francisco water doesn't really
make your dough taste great,
but it makes it perform,
makes the yeast come out,
makes the pockets better.
It does make it feel better.
It does all sorts
of great things.
I don't like chlorinated
water, super hard water.
I like to use filtered
water or reverse osmosis.
Or San Francisco, I
don't do anything.
The water in San
Francisco's great.
I was making dough
in Walnut Creek.
Compared to San Francisco, I
used 1/2% to 1% more water.
Just was a little
harder over there.
A rule of thumb is
if your water's hard,
you back off on the
salt a little bit.
If the water's soft,
you'd up your salt.
Typically, when you have your
batches, baker's percentages.
I have 100 pounds of
flour in my batch,
and I say make it 2% salt.
Well, that means
two pounds, right?
If I said make it 60% hydration,
it's 60 pounds to 100.
It's always based on
your flour weight.
A rule of thumb is 2% to
your flour weight salt
is always a good number.
If I'm tasting my water
and it's super hard
and I can't do
anything about it,
I would back off on
my salt, because salt
makes your dough strong.
It makes it hard, and makes
the gluten net very stiff.
So I would back it off 1/2.
When I won in Naples and I was
at the hotel, a rule of thumb
is you taste the water,
tastes horrible, don't use it.
All the Canada-- all
these guys, Japan,
were all making their dough.
Everybody was
talking about water.
They use bottled water.
They all went to the store
and bought bottled water.
I didn't, because I said
to myself, guys in Naples
aren't buying bottled water.
I bet you the sulfur
flavor I taste
will be more common to
these Neapolitan judges,
if I'm making a pizza that I
really have Neapolitan judges,
and they want to say, this
tastes like Naples dough.
I actually did the opposite.
It was probably the only time
in my life I would ever--
I would never use that water.
It just didn't
taste right to me,
but it tasted right to them.
So I didn't tell all the
other international people,
but it was good.
It was good.
AUDIENCE: So I've done
a lot of experimentation
at home with the Jeff
[? Farzano ?] 1995 website that
scrolls forever, and just
tried out a million things.
That I have a baking
steel rather than a stone.
And I get as close to the
broiler as I can, et cetera.
I was just wondering
how close you
think I can come to something
that-- I've run standards
on the differ-- something
that feels like a fairly
authentic Neapolitan pie, given
that my temperature's going
to be lower.
TONY GEMIGNANI: So in a home
oven, how do I get close to it?
Yeah, baking steels, broiler
method, that's the key.
Cleanout cycle, you've
probably done that.
You can't have this here,
but this is illegal.
You can't do it,
if you try it, you
can get a high heat
on cleanout cycle.
Don't do that.
Don't break your oven.
Broiler method, yes.
We've learned a lot
in cooking at home
that all the ovens cycle off.
All of them-- Wolf, during
the experiments, we had Wolf
and we had Viking.
There's different cycles.
So if you have an oven
that's preheated too long--
I had somebody say I had it
preheated for three and 1/2
hours.
And it was too hot,
and it cycled off.
And it was cooking
like it was at 400.
So cycling, careful
on your ovens.
Don't preheat it too
long, but you definitely
want to preheat it
for at least an hour.
The baking steels are
great, upper-level broiler,
and a little bit
of a sugar content
to help it caramelize a little.
Typically, that's not found
in a Neapolitan dough recipe.
But for that, you'll
see in my book
that I talk about
all that, trying
to get it as close as you can.
If you do it perfectly, you'll
get a two-minute bake almost,
two and a 1/2.
It's hot.
You have to 1/4 or 1/2-turn it.
Convection bake works well.
We didn't talk about
it much in our book,
because not everybody
has convection bake.
People will say, hey, why don't
you talk about convection bake?
Well, when it comes to reality
of everybody else in society,
it's everybody does have bake.
Not everybody does convection
bake, so we base it on bake.
Convection bake works well.
It cuts off about a minute
or two of your bake time,
just because of
circulation of heat.
So those help.
A lot times-- I did a recipe
for a pretty big magazine.
And I gave them a
Neopolitan recipe.
And they were busting
me up, saying,
why do you have sugar in it?
I said,well, because
unfortunately,
the American people and their
home ovens are off by 400
degrees, right?
So you have to.
And you've got to explain
why, when they make it
out of your magazine, why it's
coming out like cardboard.
It's crispy.
It's almost cracker-like if you
try 00 flour in a 500-degree
oven.
It's the opposite
ends of the earth.
You'll make this recipe,
and you'll be trying it.
This is not Neopolitan.
It's horrible, because
it's the wrong flour
for the temperature.
So I had to explain to
them that all the recipes I
had in the past
don't call for sugar.
I don't use it, but you
have to put in parentheses
saying, for a home
oven, you should
add some malt or sugar or some
sort of browning agent, which
is important, because
the recipes not going
to look like the picture,
if that makes sense.
And it was a pretty big
magazine I was fighting over
and they finally put it,
because I said you have to.
AUDIENCE: So that's in the
book, a lot of that stuff?
TONY GEMIGNANI: Yeah,
it's all in the book.
I have a wood-fired section.
I have a section that I
thought was a key in the book,
because there's not that
many pizza books that
have wood-fired or
home, or talking
about the different
methods and the techniques.
But baking steels-- two
steels are the way to go,
not just one.
Stones or steels, two
are the way to go.
It's always great to
start your pizza on one,
cook it halfway, and then
finish it on the other.
In the pizza business,
do we cook in one spot
and never leave it?
No.
If we have an oven like
this, I throw a pizza in.
I cook it in that circle.
That's the cool spot.
Everything else in that platform
in my oven is a hot spot.
Do we-- when we finish
cooking that pizza,
do we move it to a hotspot
and finish that bottom
and take it out?
So on a home oven, when
you have one stone,
am I able to finish it anywhere?
You're not, because you don't
have another secondary surface.
So on less than two
stones or two steels,
it'll make your bottom
totally different.
AUDIENCE: If you're
a home chef and you
want to start making
great pizza, what's
the easiest thing to start with?
TONY GEMIGNANI: What's the
easiest thing to start with?
Meaning like what should
you buy, what you invest in?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Say you're just learning
to cook great pizza.
TONY GEMIGNANI:
Just learning how--
some of the most important
things, two steels
will work great.
You have to have an oven.
I'm just joking.
Flour's important.
For a home oven, high-gluten,
high-protein flour.
When you look at
all-purpose flour,
we don't use all-purpose
flour, typically.
So let's just say you
have King Arthur Flour.
If you're looking
at Sir Lancelot,
that's a flour that's better.
It's a higher-protein.
Giusto's performer is a
great flour that you can buy.
You have to go invest in a
high-gluten, high-protein
flour.
Put a browning agent in
your dough, a sugar, a malt,
a honey, a molasses, something
that will help it caramelize.
At 500 degrees in
the pizza business,
pretty much everybody
has a browning agent.
But you'll see recipes
that won't have it.
It's important.
I have it in my book, and
I talk a lot about it.
Making your dough
mature overnight--
don't use it the same day.
Using cold water, 80%
cold water, 20% warm.
Activate your yeast
in warm water,
but cool it down
with cold water.
Doing a slow-rise
method is important.
Don't use all 104-degree water,
like you're making bread,
and like a lot of books say.
It's not what we do.
We don't use hot water.
We use cold, and then some warm
water to let it rise gradually.
Those are some of the key
components, your flour.
Those are some key.
Making dough's easy.
It's not too hard.
Yeah, it's fun.
Don't take it too seriously.
There's some guys who are on
the internet who are crazy.
They're taking it so seriously.
You can have fun
with this dough.
AUDIENCE: All right, Tony.
This is all too easy.
We're speaking
about making pizza
on Earth, where we have plenty
of oxygen and great things
to cook the pizza in.
But I have friends at NASA.
And I bet you they're
probably thinking now,
so how are we going to make
all this stuff in orbit,
or on Mars, where we
have certain constraints?
The energy budget
is constrained.
The temperature in the
oven might be constrained.
So how do we go about
doing a space pizza?
TONY GEMIGNANI:
Well, you're probably
a flash-frozen
process, or space cake?
So you want to know how
do we make pizza in space?
AUDIENCE: The closest thing.
TONY GEMIGNANI:
The closest thing.
And do you think they're
going to watch this?
Are you going to tell
them to watch it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TONY GEMIGNANI: I think if they
can get a spaceship to Mars,
I think they could
figure that out, right?
That's one thing.
But there's probably a lot
of preservatives in it.
There's probably a lot of
dough conditioners, L-cysteine,
things to make the
dough not go bad,
and then a lot of
probably horrible things
to eat that will
survive for many years.
AUDIENCE: So you've got in your
North Beach restaurant a lot
of varieties of toppings,
a lot of different flavors.
And you rotate
through, sometimes.
Some will retire, and
you'll bring new ones.
So I'm wondering if you
have a particular favorite,
and if there was one combination
that you thought was going
to work out, but
really, really didn't.
TONY GEMIGNANI:
Yeah, I always say
that's like asking who's your
favorite son, like asking
a dad-- which one's
your favorite pizza.
It's funny.
Most of them have
worked out, actually.
I've retired some,
but you have to do it.
We will be changing
our menu soon.
We do it seasonally.
We do it twice a year,
and then sometimes
in the middle of
that, we'll change it.
We try and do a big
run of 5,000 menus.
But now, you're going to see
the Tony's menu changing,
that we're going to have
inserts now, more like a book
that you can open, so we can
change it on a regular basis.
When it comes to pizzas,
what didn't work?
I wouldn't put it on the
menu if it didn't work.
Did people not get it?
We had one, the rhubarb
and Scotch pizza,
with Scotch Bonnet peppers.
Confusing, tricky--
but that one,
I don't know if everyone
got the rhubarb.
San Francisco's not bad.
My other restaurants,
people don't get it.
So I have eight
restaurants, going on 12.
I'm building several
in Vegas right now.
Everything starts at
Tony's, and things
don't work in Sacramento.
In Casino, I have one.
Vegas, even though
it's Vegas, it's
still-- so I don't have
quail eggs and random items,
guanciale, on those other menus.
Yeah, the progressiveness
of Tony's pretty much
starts there.
And there's only a couple
that haven't really worked.
There's some that
are hard to make.
And my guys are like,
are you kidding me?
Eight-hour pork--
there's certain things
that we do that are just really,
really hard for the kitchen.
And that's probably
the hard one.
Right now, the Hang 10
pizza's my favorite.
It's a Korean barbecue pizza.
My friend, Daniel
Lee, who worked for me
when I was at
Paisano's, was a driver.
He has a big Korean family, had
Korean friends at restaurants.
I had a good kalbi recipe from
him, little city meat slices,
the short ribs for
me, paper-thin.
We have a three-day
marinate for that pizza.
We have a bean curd that I
get at a Korean store that
only sells it.
It's a great pizza,
and we pickled--
we did a lot of
pickling all year.
And all the pickling is
for the whole winter.
So you'll see our pickled
peppers and carrots on that.
And it's only for two
pieces on the menu,
and the Hang 10
pizza's really cool.
That's a pizza that's
way out of the box.
And you're like, I
don't know, Tony.
You're nuts.
I don't know if it's
going to be good.
It's one of the best
pizzas you'll ever have.
Yeah, it's great.
AUDIENCE: I'll try to give
the rhubarb a try, too.
TONY GEMIGNANI:
Did you try that?
AUDIENCE: No.
TONY GEMIGNANI: Yeah,
it's not on anymore.
I took it off.
I'm going to bring it back.
Throwback Thursdays now
are all the retired pizzas
that we're bringing back.
So the Soprano's this week.
There'll be some other ones
coming up in the next weeks.
But they're $13 pies, and
people have asked for them.
AUDIENCE: If you could
have a last meal,
what would that last meal be?
TONY GEMIGNANI: I've been
asked that five times.
I feel like I'm going
to die, and everyone
wants to know what
my exit strategy is.
I can't stand it.
I feel like I'm this guy who's
70 years old, and you say,
so what's your exit strategy?
If I had to know?
It's funny.
So what would I
eat, my last meal?
I said a Romana.
A couple times, I
said a Romana pizza,
because my Romanas are
almost three feet long.
And it's the first, your
second, and your third course.
So it's three courses in one.
That was one.
Who would be at
the table would be
my grandpa and my wife, my son.
That would probably be--
my parents, of course.
My grandpa-- I'd
grown up on the farm.
My grandpa is a big
part of my life.
Of course, I haven't
seen him forever.
He's long gone now.
That's why.
But I had a pretty awesome--
there was another question of,
what was your best day
of eating in your life?
One was recently in New York.
If you ever follow
me on Facebook,
I had a marathon of eating.
I had 20-something pizzas.
I had to go to old
friends, new guys.
And I was a mess.
But I had to see--
sometimes, you've
just got to see what's going on.
It's been a while since
I really had a chance
to do that in New York.
Sometimes, you're checking
on what you're doing, just
to see-- make sure
you're doing it right.
It's always cool to
double-check it and see it.
And there was one day that
I was eating a cannoli
on Mulberry St.,
walking in the rain.
And I was saying, I
was like John Travolta
eating his cannoli, after I
had seven pizzas that morning.
And it was one of those days
that you had to have-- I
was at Roberta's that
day, Prince Street Pizza
out of Soho Square.
I had all these pieces that
day that were really great.
That was a great day for me.
Another time, we went to
Italy, and my wife and I
were traveling.
And I got lost.
I stumbled onto some place
that I could never find again.
All of a sudden,
this town appeared.
And we went to this
restaurant, and it
was a four-star restaurant
in the middle of nowhere.
I don't even get how
they would even do that,
but it was one of our
best meals we ever had.
I had a Florentine steak
that came to your table.
And it was just a rare that went
to medium-rare on the table,
and it was just sizzling.
And everything came,
and it was cool.
It was one of those moments that
was unexpected, but beautiful
at the same time.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there hope for
the mass-market pizza industry?
TONY GEMIGNANI: Meaning
like frozen lines?
AUDIENCE: Or frozen
or improvements?
TONY GEMIGNANI: I think
there's a lot of improvement.
I've worked on
some frozen lines,
actually, for three years.
Everybody's doing
the same thing.
Why is frozen pizza
always the same?
It's horrible.
Well, there's only a few places
that really manufacture it.
And when you manufacture it
on a big level on a line,
It's hard to change
anything on that line.
It's a 24/7 line,
that everybody's
making these same pizzas,
because the lines are all
the same.
It's important to find a
warehouse or somebody that
could have a line
that can adapt or can
add this or do this and do that.
And that's what will make a
pizza different and better
than those.
Preservatives-- there's a
lot of extra excess in dough
that I hate.
When it comes to frozen pizza,
I hate dough conditioners.
There's one thing that,
if you look on the box,
there's a dough
conditioner on the dough,
or L-cysteine, and
stuff like that.
I can't stand it.
And you're able to make a
great frozen line without that.
So maybe you'll
see Tony's Pizza.
Well, not Tony's-- there's
already Tony's Pizza.
You've got to think
Tony G's Pizza.
We have a frozen line
coming out, pretty good.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So
with that, thank
you very much for
stopping by Google.
TONY GEMIGNANI:
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.